you can find the david pakman show
subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
there are now more than 33 000 of our
viewers and listeners who are subscribed
there for free you can post your
thoughts about any of the stories we
talk about stories you want me to talk
about or anything else that's on your
mind a few interesting posts that i
spotted this morning
user pumpkin pie
says when it comes to messaging the
right has a lot more upside from the
written house trial than the left no
matter the outcome i know this probably
isn't a popular view on a left-leaning
subreddit just hear me out i don't think
it's smart for the left to put all their
chips on the written house case agreed
if britain house is found innocent well
remember it would be not guilty the
right gets to take a victory lap
meanwhile the left left is stuck with
complaining about how unfair the world
is i'm already cringing at the meltdowns
we're gonna see if written house is
found guilty the right gets a new martyr
going into the midterms the left has to
admit the system worked which undermines
their argument about how broken the
justice system is
and ultimately seems self-contradicting
what are your thoughts i agree 100 i've
been talking about this for a long time
uh either way either way the right wins
on the written house uh trial they will
either make him a hero or they will make
him a martyr and the hero lionization
has already started i played for you the
interview that wendy written house kyle
rittenhouse's mom did with sean hannity
on fox news late last week and it was
all about kyle is the victim and he's so
great and the media is bad and the
prosecutors are bad and democrats are
bad everybody's just bad bad bad and
unfair and um if uh
we're gonna come to a fork in the road
with the verdict which could be hours
away could be days away we don't know
the jury is deliberating as we are
filming today
um if if if it's all not guilty it is
considered a vindication of what kyle
rittenhouse did
it will also embolden vigilantism the
idea that you can bring a gun into a
situation that is an optional situation
create a situation in which you feel uh
threatened for your life
uh shoot people in self-defense in the
case of joseph rosenbaum four times not
three not not once uh even though the
first shot was disabling by everything
we know
um and then be found not guilty so it
will encourage vigilantism it's going to
be that's going to be if it's all not
guilty
um if it's all guilty
it will be
a bias trial
um that never should have been filed
this kid's being made an example out of
and he's the victim and whatever time he
serves in prison will be considered his
penance as the martyr that he will be
made now there's also a completely
plausible situation where you get a mix
of things you get not guilty on the
major charges as written but maybe
guilty of some lesser included charges
or maybe guilty on one of the minor
charges and not guilty on the major
charges and then it's just going to be a
propaganda war but needless to say
uh the left has very
little
uh to gain from either outcome justice
aside whatever you believe to be justice
aside
and the right is going to be using this
kid as either a hero or a martyr uh for
the foreseeable future very very
accurate statement
um another post i want to highlight from
reflex point is what happened to the
hatred mail segment those were hilarious
with the voice actor did haters stop
sending david emails someone posted that
there were legal reasons for why we
stopped it there's no legal reasons why
we stopped hatred mail but i've told the
story before and i'll tell it again
when we stopped doing hatred mail it was
sort of in the heat of the 2020 election
i and we were receiving
way more death threats than ever
we were receiving
things in the mail that were more
concerning than ever
and in speaking with my contacts at the
fbi
and other law enforcement agencies and
kind of just go and our security
consultant quite frankly
um and going over the totality of
everything they felt listen at least for
now
the hatred mail thing is generating a
lot of noise relative to the signal
and it's going to make it harder
to more seriously take
to discern
the real threats that need to be looked
into
and so it wasn't a legal recommendation
it was really more of a security
recommendation and hatred mail guy
completely understood
and this was a time when as i've
mentioned before
fbi has shown up at the houses of people
that have sent us threats to talk to
them and evaluate whether they presented
bona fide bona fide threats and so we
made the decision because things have so
escalated and the number of threats was
so high that we want to do anything we
can not to encourage
more potential noise uh and allow us to
discern the signal will it ever come
back maybe maybe we're going to look
into that uh but we decided to cancel it
out because of the craziness of the 2020
election this also relates to as many of
you know we have we have a second studio
uh and a lot of other things that are
going on okay so it's all related to
that i think i i will leave it there
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water quattro is
the world's best high pressure water
saving shower head starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just a hundred and
nineteen dollars but nebia is giving you
ten percent off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video